that's right I'm gonna ask you questions
and just like an interrogation just like
that you buttered me out because you
brought these amazing gifts you know
just the little latches right so this
insane cake yeah my god what is in there
so it's well good stuff it's obviously
vegan it's it's German chocolate cake
how it used to be the pastry chef at
Sante for five years Brea so it even
though it's looks decadent and it is but
I don't use oil I don't use sugar at
least not refined sugar it's all made
with dates and there's no salt and it's
pretty darn good at it looks pretty
amazing yes I think you'll like it I
want you to like it as much as you the
thing that stood out for me rich most in
your book that I remember the most is
when you talked about when you detox and
you ate your first blueberry and it was
like the best blueberry ever right I
hope this is like the best cake ever for
you I think this might exceed you know
that's amazing so I should refrigerate
yeah at some point refrigerate it
it'll be fine now then and then you also
brought me this what is this that's my
rock and nut crunch that was actually
the first product I created out of
culinary school and again it's it's just
nuts seeds and fruit that's it huh
it's amazing that's good it's good for
athletes because I know athletes need
more concentrated calories I'll be
cheering them yeah it'll be very noisy
actually thank you you're welcome
so uh it's great to see you thank you
we are back here again you were one of
the original old guard on the podcast
series episode 50 song wow yeah three or
something like that's back in like 2013
you know a while back it was amazing
thank you for having me back of course
yeah I'm so excited to talk to you and I
think you know the best way to kick it
off is to kind of share a little bit
about your story I mean I know we dug
into that pretty deeply the first time
you were on but the show has grown quite
a bit yeah I'm sure there's a lot of
people listening who were not aware that
you were on the show that's right and
your story's great I mean it's so
empowering and inspirational and you
know your transformation is really
something else so so tell me about
okay so where should I begin born in
1960 in Chicago to a morbidly obese
mother and a normal weight father and
you probably know that when you have
your parents or obese or overweight you
give more chance of becoming that and so
I got fat when I was five years old and
I lived in Chicago and I don't remember
because I'm a little bit older than you
may be a lot growing up well thank you
I'll be 58 in three weeks but in the
1960s there weren't a lot of fat kids
and so when people tell me no you can't
understand what it's like to be fat
because they see me as a slender person
I was fat before it was socially
acceptable to be fat nobody was fat
there was one fat kid in every grade in
1960 to 1970 that was me so maybe I
wasn't as fat by today's standards but
when you're the fattest one you're still
the fattest one and there's a lot of
things that go on with that that are not
comfortable growing up like for instance
you can't buy your clothes at a regular
store because they don't fit and so
became fat at five but by eleven I was
actually obese
I weighed 160 pounds and I'm five six I
don't love it at 11 but I wasn't five
six then I wasn't even 5 feet then so I
was obese and you know it's not fun and
it doesn't matter how fat you are still
it's not fun if you're fat and you're
uncomfortable in your own body so I
didn't realize that I was actually
suffering from what I know today to be a
food addiction and addiction to refined
food specifically things like sugar and
flour and I continued to become fatter
and fatter I got into about the
200-pound range in my 20s but I was
vegan this is the weird thing at the age
of 17 when I was a freshman at the
University of Pennsylvania I was
studying to be a veterinarian and
instead of became a vegetarian because
the first day on the job I was handed a
tank of live salamanders and the doctor
said to cut their heads off I said why
he goes well we're doing protein lens
regeneration experiments in the
amphibian and I just need their eyes
well I was on scholarship and there's
something about you see a guy in a white
coat and I cut off one head and I was
like terrible I started vomiting I went
to the Student Health Center and I said
I would never eat another animal again
or harm one or wear one so became a
vegan on September 1st 1977 yeah not
cool back then yes that was four
and I imagine not easy either no no we
didn't even have powdered soymilk in
1977 now you can go to any town anywhere
in the United States $0.99 store Walmart
and you get plant milk in probably ten
different varieties Alton soy and rice
there was nothing well there wasn't
nothing there was a whole natural food
like fruits vegetables and whole grains
and legumes and nuts and seeds but
that's not what I ate I was a sugar
addict I didn't know it at the time but
looking back starting every day with a
coke Slurpee with eight pumps of vanilla
syrup and having a dr. pepper big gulp
48 ounces every day of lunch
not exactly a health promoting diet so I
did this every day till I was about 43
years old 26 years of my veganism was
basically eating candies cakes cookies
pies and ice cream and so of course I
became course I became during that
period of time were you trying to
resolve this issue like were you going
on diets and trying to restrict your
calories and doing all the things that
you know we do yeah so I tried this one
diet in my teens which was called
anorexia where I didn't eat and actually
it is obstructed for a while it works
beautifully it's not sustainable you
know so I tried that in my teens and
ended up hospitalized and so that wasn't
good because let there were so many
complications my hair fell out my nails
you know I developed an enlarged liver
that wasn't very fun but the thing about
anorexia is the minute I started eating
again I didn't start eating the way that
you eat and I eat now I went back right
away to the junk food and then I gained
even more weight and actually what a lot
of people don't know and they'll find
out in my book is I actually attempted
suicide because then I became bulimic
and in a lot of ways that was worse than
anorexia for me because I didn't like
being anorexic but there was it wasn't
that hard so in other words to be
anorexic all I had to do was not eat but
bulimia required extraordinary efforts
because the binging and the purging and
the laxatives use and the
over-exercising
bulimia was a 24-hour job so was
anorexia but anorexia you're basically
cold and tired you don't have any energy
to do anything and so that's when I
attempted suicide at the age of 19 and I
never told anybody this not even my
husband till about three years ago yeah
I mean I read that in your book I was
like wait I don't think I knew now I've
KC we didn't talk about that last
I'd never heard yeah it's not something
was really comfortable talking about but
then when I started when I spoke at the
MacDougall conference he insisted I tell
my life story and I didn't think it was
fair to leave that out especially since
coming out as a food addict or food
addict in recovery now so many people
have written me saying that they've
contemplated suicide and attempted
suicide because of their discordant
relationship with food so I figure well
I'll tell people yeah I was a dark
period I mean yeah so walk me through
that a little bit I mean you know what I
mean I can't imagine the level of
despair yeah yeah it's like I tried I
remember the day at April 1st you know
and I it's funny because I don't usually
think about this but it's interesting
because I I do personally believe in God
ain't no a lot of people don't but
that's the only explanation for why I'm
alive because I didn't tell anybody
I didn't even leave a note and I had
stolen um I never had to talk about this
my grandfather was a medical doctor and
I stole medicine from his house my
grandfather my grandmother was diabetic
she was on a lot of stuff and I just
just stole your work on stuff I just
just all her my grandmother's pills I
don't remember the names but my
grandmother took a lot of pain
medication so I know it was in that
realm of pain medication and I never
drank alcohol but I remember drinking a
bunch of alcohol and taking a bunch of
these pills and remember twas Passover
and I didn't go because I had planned to
kill myself that night and what was
really interesting is my grandfather who
I'm had stolen the pills from he showed
up at my door he said he said I don't
know why I've been directed to come here
and and then you know then you know they
take you in an ambulance and they pump
your stomach and then opinioned up in a
mental hospital which is like worse
because that they don't that's you know
and you have the meant it was not fun
I'll tell you how old were you then I
was um I was 20 yeah yeah so do you
think that looking back on it now with
some perspective that was it a tried and
true suicide attempt not quite for hell
no it was tried I mean it was for me I
you know I was tried and true because I
didn't tell anybody
I didn't leave a note and I took a lot
of the pills I mean I don't know if it
would have worked but there was a lot
you're still alert when your grandfather
no I don't
remember vaguely a shadow of him saying
that you know I I just felt like I had
to come here because you didn't show up
to the Passover Seder and yeah that so I
want to get into like how you recover
from something like that and the path
forward but but I don't want to move too
far away from this subject of food
addiction like I don't want to just
brush over sure I think it's a super
important topic that deserves a little
bit more of a deep dive and I think
there's a lot of confusion about it what
does it actually mean is it even really
a thing so describe to me your
perspective on food it's true because it
is not really a thing yet to many people
because it's not in the DSM so a lot of
doctors won't acknowledge it even some
of the plant-based doctors so to me what
food addiction means is refined food
addiction you're not really addicted to
food and eating if you don't eat you'll
die but there are particular foods for
specifically foods like sugar and flour
that are very highly refined
carbohydrates that certain people are
very vulnerable to the effect of so that
when we ingest them they have a more
drug like behavior than food like
behavior and as a recovering alcoholic
I'm sure you understand that there are
people out there that can drink alcohol
in varying amounts and not become an
alcoholic awesome right but there's
certain people like you one drink one
drunk and there's people in the world
like my husband they can eat sugar and
flour in almost any amount and be
slender and healthy and not have
cravings but there's other people that
even a little bit like maybe if it's the
fifth ingredient in a barbecue sauce
will set us off and we'll set off the
phenomenon known as craving where all we
do is want more and more and more it
sets off that insatiable desire for more
yeah it's insidious for those that
suffer from it and I I think you know I
started doing a lot of deep thinking
about addiction and and what it is
specifically and what it's not and I
really think that we need to have a
broader conversation and expand the
definition of what we mean when we talk
about addiction it's not just drunks and
people that can't keep a needle out of
their arm
you know I think on some level it's this
on some level I think all of humanity
suffers to some extent from some type of
compulsive behavior or thought pattern
or substance you know and food is
certainly a part of that
but it is a spectrum right and so where
do you fall on that right room that's
why it's so hard I think because it's a
spectrum you know and because some
people can have a little and some people
there are people that identify with the
title of food attic but maybe can have
the barbecue sauce is a condiment with
the fifth ingredient and because it
exists on a continuum it's so hard to
quantify words like with high blood
pressure we can say if your blood
pressure is this you're hypertensive and
there's no real direct test for it yeah
and and the substance is whether its
food or or a drug is the catalyst the
the the condition really has to do with
your mental emotional and physiological
state you know there's a certain person
who's going to be sensitive like you
said to sugar or alcohol or cocaine and
it's going to activate them in a way
that it isn't for somebody else but
ultimately the addiction lies within the
soul really I mean it's you're you're
trying to alter your state your state of
mind your physiological state and you're
reaching out often you know mostly
compulsively but often even
unconsciously to medicate yourself in
some way because you have some level of
discomfort right and sugar hits the spot
for a lot of people but it's about
getting at the root of what is
activating that and something that I
thought was really cool and interesting
about your book is that you get into the
emotional trauma that you suffered as a
young person and you know I think that
there is a direct nexus between the
trauma that we suffer as young people
and how we kind of navigate the world as
adults and I've explored this at length
on the podcast I had gab or monta on the
show he's all about that I love him and
so to hear you speak to that I think is
really powerful so walk me through kind
of what that experience was like as a
young person because you know you did
have some challenge I I thank you for
asking that I first I want to agree with
what you say about how addiction often
starts because of something like
that trying to medicate feel better
especially as a child when you're
helpless you know you know you can't go
to a bar and have a drink or things like
that but I think that often it continues
because now it is an addiction does that
make sense so like when I was 43 years
old and happily married I was still
using not because of what happened to me
when I was five but because I was really
addicted there was so much energy behind
that that that happened at that way
right yeah so you know my father was
psychotic he is not his fault he was
kicked in the head by a horse when I was
little like psychotic like like
clinically like yes like he was and I
didn't know him before the accident but
the people that did like my grandmother
said that that changed him now today he
would have been in a neurologist there
would have been MRIs but he my dad had a
gash in his head from being kicked in
the head by a horse and that changed his
behavior so he was violent and he was
abusive to pretty much everybody in my
family
he never physically hit me and my sister
which was interesting but in a way I had
survivor's guilt because he hit my
brothers and my mom but the worst was
watching him torture my dog and and
that's it's interesting because I think
the reason I became vegan so young is
because I couldn't protect my dog from
my dad and he would just he would just
brutally beat I love my dogs I love dogs
I saw a dog here I love dogs so much and
that was my best friend Snoopy and
Snoopy was an epileptic and he would
have seizures and my dad would just beat
my dog and I couldn't do anything about
it and that was the worst thing is like
you know my brothers and my brothers
were older my mom was an adult not that
it's good to watch humans being beat
either but like when it's a defenseless
animal like that and I hated him so much
and like I wanted to kill him but like
when you're five what do you do you know
and so you know you have cookies do you
think do you think your dad's rage or
anger outbursts are I mean what was that
an expression of I mean it was it just a
neurological tweak because of the injury
I I didn't know him before I mean okay I
don't know if I should even say this
because then people think I'm really
crazy but I did contact a medium that
could talk to him since yeah okay so I
finally did a few years ago and
part of it was his personality but the
thing is the personality plus the injury
just made a bad situation worse mm-hmm I
know and what about your mom my mom was
a helpless victim she was you know she
had four kids so it's not like she
didn't have a job so it's not like she
could leave and I don't think there were
shelters back then but finally she got
the courage to leave they were married
gosh a long time I think it was when I
was 11 finally when he brutally attacked
her she finally my grandparent my
grandfather thank God for my grandfather
finally got her to finally leave once
and for all so yeah you know I grew up
kind of scared because he was really
mean and I was really little and I
couldn't really do anything about it
back then and you know there's nobody to
talk to back then about it do you have a
specific memory of turning to food to
comfort you or is it just a blur of like
you know it just was always there trying
to think if there was an actual incident
it kind of was always there because it
was in the environment you know we had
all the treats there so it that's a good
question I'm gonna I'm gonna let it
marinate because I right now but you
grew up with Froot Loops and Oreo oh my
god that stuff yeah and you know it's
funny because my mom would pack my lunch
I went to school and one of the things
that one of the again you know I think
about these things as traumatic memories
but when I went to school there I
sometimes go to this place called
farmers market a third and Fairfax and
they sell these vintage lunchboxes and
all the kids had those but mine was gray
like the construction workers the big
gray lunchbox with the thermos and when
I think back to the kind of food she fed
me because obviously she was a food
addict herself I mean I wouldn't just
have like one little dessert like I
would have liked the whole double thing
of Suzie Q and then I would have a soda
I would have like just it part of it was
just that I wasn't being fed the right
food either that I was fed a diet that
was going to probably make me fat and
sick unless my genetics were such that
it wasn't so part of it was that let's
see I just you know I remember I have to
I had to crawl on this counter to get to
the good stuff in the thing and I
remember them you know the box cereals
like Lucky Charms I remember picking out
the charms I wouldn't eat the lucky
because lucky was the was the oat bran
thing that was terrible I just wanted
the marshmallow all right so you're in
you
fifth sixth seventh grade you're the one
overweight child in your class and I
remember that too there was you know
there was generally one kid who
struggled with his weight or her weight
now it's very different
lots of kids it's more like most kids at
some schools but that had to be I would
imagine I don't want to project onto you
but but I would imagine you know that's
isolating yeah you know I was lucky that
I was funny and I was I made up you know
is the kind of thing we're like since
I've done stand-up comedy of another
Tonight Show one of the things they
learn is is that you make fun of
yourself before they make fun of you and
so I was very funny
I was I was intelligent I was always the
teacher's pet I was very bright but I
was really funny and so people still
like me even though I was fat I mean the
boys didn't like me I mean they liked me
because I could do their homework but
they didn't like me like like like they
would like a normal girl so I didn't get
a lot of teasing you know there was a
little bit but it wasn't like the
bullying that goes on today because I
really was popular because I was funny
and people like funny people you know
it's so hard to imagine you like 200
pounds like I can't even I can't even
answer it in ninety I think was 94 we
have this huge earthquake in Los Angeles
and that was in Sherman Oaks and I lost
everything except for you know the
clothes that I had and so all the
pictures because the water pipe broke or
going so I don't have pictures at that
weight but if you go to my YouTube page
chef AJ and watch me on The Tonight Show
you'll see me at least at 180 but I I
did say have a pair of shorts oh my god
that I kissed aware so these were pretty
big yeah those look like 42 yeah so so I
do have that and then I have also
pictures you know not quite 200 but you
know most of them topped out at 164
right right right
that's wild so all right so let's pick
it back up from you know that after this
suicide attempt I mean was that a like a
moment of reckoning where you're like I
got to figure this out you know what
happened after no no it was dark
I just with this shame and humiliation
my brother's a psychiatrist I mean so it
was like kind of brought a lot of shame
to my family and you know I remember you
know people saying to me why don't you
just pull yourself up by your bootstraps
and I'm like
you know it's like saying alcohol you
know why don't you just stop drinking
right it's not that easy if and so you
know I was depressed and it was it was
it was bad it was bad and how long did
that you know was how long was I in the
hospital for it I you know they put you
if they put you in a locked ward of a
mental hospital how long were you there
I want to see like three months and whoa
and it was it was it's crazy I mean
because some of the people there I mean
no disrespect to mentally ill people are
actually crazy and so it's it's it's
sort of like in prison like they mix
like hardened criminals with with less
hardened criminals they just put
everybody together and there's something
about when that door closes you know you
can't get out and I remember my mom
visiting me with my dog and it it's just
you know it's almost like I didn't know
you're gonna ask about this or I would
have brushed up on my past cuz it's
really something I don't think about but
it was it was not a good period of
months so did they have you on a battery
of all kinds of crazy well they were you
know it's they tried medicine see you
know I'm I'm lucky then I'm a real
sensitive and allergic person because
none of them seem to work and none of
them either I would throw up or get a
rash so no I was they didn't put me on
Thorazine thank goodness and were they
just warehousing you or were you getting
help like you know I thank you you know
either you go to it you know you go to
groups you know I mean that not again I
don't want to sound like I'm belittling
them but like you know they have like
our therapy and music therapy and and
psychodrama so I mean they don't if I
wish I had remembered it more if I knew
I was gonna be at a point in my life
where I'd be able to tell the story I
would have taken notes cuz it would have
made a brilliant
you know like comedic movie at some
point you meet it but also you know yeah
it is that thing like once you're in
like you know a lot of people never make
it out ya know it's it was it's really
really scary it's it's it I don't wish
it on anybody and maybe they're better
now but but you want you want to hear a
funny story so it later in life I became
a respiratory therapist and it's a it's
a it's like a like an allied health
profession where we go around with Lake
machines and give breathing treatments
it's like in the hospital and I ended up
working at the same hospital where I was
locked up as a mental patient but the
mental hospital is across the street and
I never liked going there to give the
breathing treatments because I thought I
got what if they lock me up again
because it is a big attack
yeah so it's not like because most
people up until now or you know nobody
knew about this but I'm never going
there to give a breathing treatment to a
patient and then I saw a patient that
was one of the staff members when I was
hospitalized in other words the people
that were our staff still they're just
as crazy as the people they were trying
to help and again I apologize if people
are offended by crazy I mean it like in
a more loving way I don't mean crazy but
but the people that was my psychiatric
aide when I was hospitalized was now an
incoherent to psychiatric patient this
the staff person became a patient and I
was like oh my god I couldn't believe it
it's like and these are the people that
we're tending to us it's it's it's scary
you know that's heavy it's very scary so
so you get out of that then what happens
oh my god so I went that I had to go
back to live with my mom I couldn't go
back to the University of Pennsylvania
and you know she basically said you have
to get a job and I am trying to remember
what it's like my 20 it's like my 20s
were a blur but eventually you know I
did get a job I actually I got a fun job
actually I became a dog walker believe
it or not and I remember I was the dog
walker from Michael J Fox and that was
the funnest job I ever had he had good
like the plum dog it's like it's like
literally he was so generous and he had
two beautiful golden retrievers named
Jamie and Rosie that he wanted taken out
for like several hours twice a day and
at that time I was like the only only
client I needed like that was the best
job I ever had and so you were out here
oh that was yeah I lived here I moved
here in 1971 from Chicago right yeah
gotcha
alright so let's play this forward when
when does it when's the final reckoning
moment with weight like you know I know
you have sure fits and starts right
you're taking stabs at we have this
under control
wait walk me through that to the
breaking so I like I said I'm I didn't
have a big history of dieting or trying
diets cuz I saw my mom fail at every
diet
I had the stab at anorexia from 14 to 19
which worked but was unsustainable I got
married when I was not gonna say 95 35
in 1995 is when I got married and you
know I didn't want to be a fat bride and
as luck would have it fen phen had hit
the market then it was very popular and
wasn't quite really fat enough for the
doctor said but because I had a knee
injury from all the years of
over-exercising he allowed me to have it
and I was able to get my weight down to
pretty close to what I am now
well powerful stuff yeah I arrest you in
a pill oh my god so exactly they both
work but again they're both dangerous
they're both life-threatening and
neither of them are sustainable so I was
so happy when I was on fen-phen because
it allowed me to keep eating the crap
that I was eating but it tricked my
brain into thinking I was cool so I
could eat just smaller amounts of crap
which were you all jacked up to it
actually had an antidepressant effect on
me so it actually made me feel really
good I felt fantastic on it things
rolled off my back like water off a
duck's back how long were you on it I
was on it for probably six months oh
that's that's pretty long I don't you
get a tolerance though take more well
yeah you do but here's what happened it
got removed the FDA took it away so and
I remember this shows waking it was to
drugs right yeah it was fed to me infant
flora mean that it separately works okay
but together were like this magic bullet
that was going to annihilate annihilate
the obesity epidemic so what happened is
people are getting heart lung damage
like from it and so I remember going to
the mailbox one day and there was a
letter from the FDA and I'm like well I
see FDA writing me you know
well they had removed it from the market
we were told to stop taking it and to go
immediately to a cardiologist you have
an echocardiogram so I was fine but I
really still wanted the drug so I went
online and I tried to buy it in other
countries but I couldn't buy the potent
combination I could only about the by I
believe the phentermine illegally
there's no Silk Road then didn't work so
guess what within three months the
weight came right back on
I learned to nothing and so I just
assumed that I was destined to be fat
160 165 I just figured that's my
setpoint mom was fat my grandma was fat
my great-grandma that's it so I'll just
learn to accept their makeup genetically
predetermined I figured that's it
you know and I remember because as a
vegan that you know I had started to
teach cooking and I remember thinking
you know like it was a little bit
embarrassing because you think of people
in the vegan world that are like
influencers like you know if you got
like Mary MacDougall she's very
trim and you know and Esselstyn and I
just figured you know it's not in my
cards it's and so I was gonna do the
best I couldn't but what was happening
as I started teaching I remember
teaching at Whole Foods Pasadena when
they opened that big store and I was
very popular as a culinary teacher I had
the biggest class 77 people and I was
doing a culinary class and remember this
gentleman raises his hand you know I'm
thinking is gonna ask about the garlic
or the onion he said ago yeah he goes if
the vegan diets so good why are you so
fat and I felt like saying I don't know
why he's such an [ __ ] but I did
called it yeah and then people were
saying once I started putting these
little videos on YouTube people were
saying the same thing it was generally
men saying Matt and my husband would
delete the comments and it didn't it
didn't really hurt my feelings so much
because they were right because I really
didn't know why I was so fat I really
liked then I found out and I went to a
place culture north and January of 2011
what what motivated you to go there
though yeah this is it this is
interesting it wasn't because I was fat
I find my first book on process I talk
about my string of fetal deaths were the
the babies weren't quite yet born but I
had four miscarriages right one after
the other yeah yeah and the first one
was like almost a live birth and so that
set me into a pretty bad depression this
was in to thin the year 2000 February
1st 2000 was when the first baby died
the one that was almost born and I was
40 years old and so it was tough it but
it had four of these in a row and at the
same time my mom and my dad and my dog
died so it was like so I was I was like
I developed something called panic
disorder and I couldn't leave my house
for a year I lost my job in my house cuz
I kept having panic attacks and I
wouldn't go on meds because I don't like
meds I don't like the it's not I just
didn't like the idea of meds especially
psych meds well well you had I would
imagine you associate that with being
it's like that's a highway back yeah I
don't want to be on psych meds you know
and especially because again I'm vegan I
keep thinking one vegan I should you
know what diet should be enough I should
be able to you know do this right the
promise I had already had that major
depressive episode you know in childhood
which again sets you up for another one
so I was depressed but now it wasn't
just depression I was having panic
attacks and I they're scary because you
know
I'd be walking my had two dogs at the
time and I'd be walking them I'd get a
panic attack and then I lose control of
my arms and then the dogs would go and
so it got so scary especially when I was
driving that I just checked out and I
just stayed home for nine months well
shut down like a Nagori agoraphobia and
so the problem was if you don't go to
work for nine months you know they you
don't make any money and so so what
happened was is this is actually
outlined on a show called The Dog
Whisperer with Cesar Millan is I found
out that my dog Sparky at the time was
able to predict if I was going to have a
panic attack he just knew just kind of
like my grandfather right right like he
could sense it and so if it was coming
on he could he just like he would stare
at me he would pop me he would lick me
he would bark and I didn't train him to
do this and so I the promise he was a
little bit dog aggressive and I found
out there was a thing called a
psychiatric service dog a service dog
and what happened was is I he I went on
the dog whisperer and and he became my
service dog and I was able to re-enter
the workforce using the service dog go
back to work and I did start taking
medication at the second I went on I
went on the dog whisperer
well so what happened was is okay sir
I'm getting ahead of myself a lot of
this I just called up c-czar I wish I
could do that so what happened was is I
saw on an the LA Times we had a paper we
had a newspapers back then the Sunday
Times I believe this would have been
2006 now or 2005 and I the show had only
been on one season he wasn't it's huge
of a star then as he is now because this
was season casting for season two
and I found out because my psychiatrist
was willing to write me a letter because
to have this dog because if I felt safe
with him because I knew that if he if he
could predict that I was gonna have a
panic attack if I felt when coming on
and I was driving I could pull over I
could get to a safe space and so Cesar
Millan helped me get him certified so
that he would be suitable in public and
it was it was great it was a wonderful
heartwarming episode the thing is I did
go on a small amount of medication at
the urging of Believe It or Not a
naturopathic doctor who said I can't
help you you need these drugs so I went
on an ant
prescient called lexapro in 2011 10
milligrams not that much and it it it
did stop me from having panic attacks it
did work the thing was is it does it
also has other effects and it just you
don't have his joyous or a vibrant his
life when you're on these medications
you're just kind of like yeah you know
so in a way it was good because here
having panic attacks you know I remember
one time the scariest panic attack was I
was taking a bath and we had at that
time a sunken tub and I got a panic
attack in the bathtub and when I was
getting panic attacks my arms and legs
would go numb and I couldn't get out of
the tub and then you just end up being
naked and freezing it was really scary
so so I went on this medicine but again
I wasn't really having it like you say
it was more of a flat effect I wasn't
really having a joyous life and plus I
didn't like the idea of being on
medication you know and I tried to get
off them by titrating the dose I went to
these specialists I flew around the
world and I could lower it to seven
point five two five to two point five
but the minute I went lower than two
point five the panic attacks were coming
back and I went back on so in about 2010
I heard about a book called the pleasure
trap by dr. Lyle dr. Goldhamer my two
mentors and now friends and I read the
book it's a great book by the way about
addiction and and more and I found out
that dr. Goldhamer had this Center in
Santa Rosa California and that if you
fill out the form online you can have a
free consult so I did that and I said
listen I'm on this psychiatric medicine
I'd really prefer not to be on it can
you help me I was I was bad but that's
not what wasn't about weight loss not
yet but it's interesting because that
opened the door because then I met the
secret weapon him in dr. Lisle and he
said yeah you're gonna come to the
center I'm gonna put you on disability
we're gonna fast you for six weeks and
we'll get you off the meds well I get to
true north Martin Luther King jr.
birthday weekend of 2011 I go with a
friend of mine Tim you know for support
and my service dog Sparky and the first
thing you do before you water fast to
see one of the actual medical doctors he
said can't fast on psych meds so
couldn't fast they did a juice fast you
know but the thing is is what happened
as I met dr. Doug Lyall who is the best
you should interview him he is so no I'd
love to have him on I've heard him speak
many times I love the book look has come
out
and you know the book is gonna be on
audio now mm-hmm and guess who got to
record it I don't know you yes I was I
know that's like the Vig that's like the
biggest feather in my cap that I was a
full circle moment for you know what it
is because it was like neither of them
wanted to do it but the publisher needed
the book out and because I I relative
Lee understood the material they let me
do it so it was really very nice this is
yeah January 2011 that's not that long
ago I thought like this went way back
for you much further back well the
trauma and trauma goes further back but
this no I know yeah sort of turning
point for no is much more recent than I
recall I'm the nouveau Finn I've only
been thin for about six years now so
yeah so I met dr. Lisle who's who's
fabulous and I loved his book in his
lecture so I actually had a you know
epic an individual appointment with him
then and again we still hadn't talked
about weight loss then it was just about
can you help me with my panic disorder
and he helped me more in that one
session then all the doctors did my
whole line went up there for the session
or was that on the top there because he
he works there he works there any works
at the mcdougal program both in Santa
Rosa and he gave me some really good
techniques explain what panic disorder
wasn't he really helped me so I still
could not yet get off medication I tried
and then it was now September of that
year and what happened and this is
interesting because I really believe
that sometimes when things in life and
you you might believe this - there's no
real accidents it's sometimes when
things are difficult and painful in the
moment you look back and you go wow that
was really a blessing so we're now
talking in my life yeah right yeah so
September of 2011 like I was really
embarrassed that I was on psych meds and
I didn't want anybody to know I felt
that as a personal failure like that
what's wrong with me that I have to take
these drugs and what's wrong with me
that I can't get off of them because
they tell you they're not addictive but
they are because you can't get off of
them so in September of 2011 I got a job
as chef AJ like doing a really cool
presentation at a high-end kind of thing
and I got there and is gonna be there
for almost a week in New York and I
forgot my meds and my doctor of course
would have written a prescription for me
and I could have got them but the people
that I were staying with said oh no
problem so and so their neighbor was a
pharmacist just tell me what you need
and we'll get it for you and I was too
embarrassed
as it turns out a month I rose on
I really meds too so I just said well
this well after not taking him for a
week you go through huh yeah it's it's
hot that's not the way to get off psych
meds by the way it's sort of like if you
ever very you were titrated down to a
prism no I was back up to ten I was back
up to ten if you ever saw those dolls
they're like gray and you the rubber and
you squeeze them in their eyes pop out
and their ears pop out when you go off
psych meds like that you actually it's
almost like you feel your brain wiring
and it's not a pleasant thing and like
you have to kind of lay there in the
dark and you it was a horrible horrible
experience but I was so embarrassed I
went through this and Doug Lyall dr. Lao
really helped me through it he called my
husband I was it was not pretty going
through this detox but after I got
through it just like anything else you
know that withdrawal sucks so you but
you were staying with people at the time
being with people and that you didn't
tell them that this was going on I was
too embarrassed I was I was still able
to do your event or I was I was able to
do my job and I was able to do it well
but the rest of the time I just kind of
laid there like in a fetal position just
feeling my brain just go crazy but I got
through it and just the same thing
whether it's drugs or alcohol or food
food withdrawal is a [ __ ] but addiction
I think is worse actually but when you
get through it you know what it's like I
mean have you ever met anybody and
recovery from anything that ever said
you know was much better back then
no so it's so I was off it and it was
great and by now I had some techniques
some actual cognitive behavioral
techniques that I learned from dr. Lisle
about what to do when I had a panic
attack work okay
for example all the other doctors said
oh you need to meditate you need to
breathe well when you're in the throes
of a panic attack you can't all of a
sudden ask your body to relax so dr. Lai
would say no what you do is you run in
place you do jumping jacks you do panic
disorders like there's a lion you need
to run I was what they there's fight
flight or freeze I was a freezer and dr.
Lisle taught me no you have to run I go
but what happens when I'm having you
know I'm in the car
because you just squeeze your arms like
this with the steering wheel so I was
able to use the techniques he taught me
and what happened is do I still get
panic attacks occasionally but the
stakes have to be high now like like
there was a pit bull in the neighborhood
coming towards me I got a panic attack
but a regular person might have to right
Oh
in a car accident a couple years ago I
got a panic attack but I'm not having
with the threat exactly but whereas
before nothing would happen and so so
yeah so so that's what happens so I was
using dr. Lisle really for panic
disorder and psychiatric medication
withdrawal he told me to read a book
called anatomy of an epidemic which
explains that these medicines not only
don't work most of the time but actually
are harmful and that in trials clinical
trials placebo was more effective and so
if I had read that book I would not have
chosen to go on meds but I was starting
to work as chef AJ in the vegan world
conference here and there dr. McDougall
had had me a couple of times and in the
the weekend after Thanksgiving 2011 dr.
Lyle and I we'd become friendly we were
on a job together and at a break I said
to him I said Doug good to go home dog I
said I know that you hear this all the
time
because now by then I was eating a
really health promoting diet by the way
I needed to backtrack a little bit from
August 1st 2008 when I first heard dr.
Esselstyn speak I stopped eating sugar
oil and salt I was eating a health
promoting diet and I wasn't eating the
mass copious amounts of candies cakes
cookies pies and ice creams I was able
to make rich date-nut treats but I
wasn't eating sugar oil salt but I was
still 50 pounds heavier and I couldn't
figure out why I know now why and it's
in the book but I said to him I said
Doug I said I swear to you I'm not
cheating I'm eating a whole food diet I
don't eat sugar oil salt why am I so fat
and he basically sat me down and
explained calorie density to me which is
yeah and this has become your thing I
mean I've seen you give your your
keynote presentation many times and it's
super powerful but it's also like oh
yeah duh yeah I like it it's so
Elementary in many ways but I think the
concepts elude most people so so you
know walk us through that because I
think it's really important information
right but no one had also sorry to but I
think you know it helps with this
confusion that you've lived through
between what it means to eat a vegan
diet and what it means to eat a whole
food plant-based diet and what it means
to eat like you know the ultimate sort
of health promoting longevity promoting
disease reversing type of diet because
those are very different and I've been
through them all you know so yes thank
you
a great question so I was eating a whole
food plant-based diet without sugar oil
salt I wasn't cheating but not having
understood caloric density I was eating
way too much of the whole plant foods
that were calorically dense such as the
nuts the seeds the avocados and the
dried fruit and there's nothing wrong
with those fruits and athletes such as
yourself you need those calories but
somebody that's a female and as dr.
Goldhamer says females are energy
conserving estrogen producing fat
storage machines and somebody that was
already fat didn't need so many calories
from those calorically dense foods even
though they they they have nutrients and
they have fiber and when dr. Lisle
explained to me what dr. mcdougal had
been saying for 40 years but for some
reason it eluded me until it was like
face-to-face and he explained it to me
the concept at least for me the fat you
eat is the fat you wear and yes there
are people that can eat more fat and not
be fat but if you're fat it might not be
you when I when I ate a more MacDougall
type diet you know and and didn't add
any fat like the weight just came off it
was like was so weird because it wasn't
even eating that many nuts I was
weighing and measuring an ounce a day
thinking I needed them or I would die
without them and I remember it was so
funny because for the dr. Lisle he's
funny he tricks you into doing things he
has you do with these experiments and so
he said to me he goes you know just for
a month I want you to not eat any added
fat no not see you know just for a month
I want you to do it and and go that's
can I say [ __ ] or yes I say that's
[ __ ] Doug I said that's not gonna
work you know nuts are healthy you gotta
have them all the doctors are saying you
gotta have at least this much he said
just do it for a month I said you know
what
you're so stupid okay I don't if I said
stupid I said I said you're wrong I'm
gonna do this for three months I'm not
gonna start until January 2nd 2012
because that's when I get back from True
North
I worked there every Christmas as a
guest chef and I want to do it for three
months because I'm gonna do it till my
birthday and show you that I'm not gonna
lose any weight and then on my birthday
I'm gonna have a rich date nut dessert
and go no well guess what dr. Lyles
always right and he was right and I was
losing a pound a week doing that I
couldn't believe how easy it was because
now I was eating more food but
calorically dilute food and in my
opinion better food because I
eating like lots of potatoes and sweet
potatoes and rice and beans so I was
filling up I was less hungry and eating
bigger volumes of food that had less
calories and it's like like you said
it's so it's so obvious but it does
elude people right so you mentioned the
MacDougall type died for somebody who's
listening who doesn't know who john
mcdougall right and kind of what he
stands for maybe it's worth seeing a
little ditty cuz yet last time I was on
I sang the gold hammer song so yeah oh I
did I remember that you let me sing the
gold hammer sighs yeah see it again John
McDougall has a plan based on
carbohydrates if you eat them you'll be
trim and not have a sore thumb a John
McDougall he's the man he's a smartest
Plato eating starch will make you thin
just eat a damn potato so did you write
that yeah I didn't write the melody
obviously it's Yankee Doodle but so so
here's where things get get sticky for a
lot of people you know and this comes up
all the time in the podcast like right
now you know there's no there's a lot of
talk and energy behind this idea that
carbohydrates are terrible you should be
eating a low carb no carb potentially
even ketosis high fat type diet which is
in total you know juxtaposition contra
position to where John McDougall is
coming from who you know who's basically
his basic principle is we're starch of
wars and we should be eating these
complex carbohydrates in natural food
form
yeah I agree with him you know I run a
program in LA and actually online too
called the ultimate weight loss program
and I have people now that have lost 100
to 300 pounds and kept it off for like
five years eating nothing but
carbohydrates so to me and it not high
in carbohydrates would be not fun it
would be sad it would be deprivation and
you know potatoes make you thin I mean
didn't you interview or did you lose 120
pounds just eating potatoes I mean they
really are the perfect food for health
and weight loss you know according to
something called the satiety index there
they are the most satisfying food in the
world but
because they're filling their souls are
also nutrient-dense absolutely have a
lot more nutrients in them than people
realize we sort of think of them as a
junk food like oh it's a white food like
it's just calories without any vitamins
and minerals but it's actually a lot of
good stuff in it but to be clear you
know we need to kind of define our terms
I mean when you say carbohydrate that
doesn't mean you know what flour sugar
alcohol like wheat pasta I don't exactly
I mean whole unrefined complex
carbohydrates whole grains in their
whole form not processed into a flour
legumes beans split peas lentils in
their whole form cooked with water and
potatoes sweet potatoes and winter
squashes these are the foods that our
ancestors ate throughout most of human
history that are still eaten parts of
the world today that are free of the
diseases like obesity and heart disease
that plague us I mean the Okinawans
according to the Blue Zones are the
longest live people in the world don't
they eat something like over 70% of
their calories from sweet potatoes so
these are foods that make you thin the
problem is as people are adding things
like oil to them for french fries and
and chips and that's the problem it's
not the carbohydrate it's the fat the
cheese the butter the oil that people
add to it that make them fat and say so
let's get back to this idea of caloric
density you know when you give your talk
you always have these the jars I almost
brought them jars and you also have
these charts where you show what a
stomach looks like right here's the
stomach with you know tons of vegetables
and it's completely full you know more
vegetables than you could possibly sit
down and eat until you're completely
stuffed
and then the caloric equivalent of that
is you know I don't know like you know
an ounce of oil in your stomach yeah
it's like it just looks like a tiny
weight of your stomach maybe two and a
half tablespoons yeah it's sinking it
doesn't even show up it puts it into
perspective in terms of calories so on
the one hand you have these foods that
are super high in fiber minerals
vitamins phytonutrients micronutrients
all those things that you need and want
and that we're always trying to get and
then on the other hand you have well
it's there's a little bit's wrong with a
little bit of all
right but you see when you see that you
realize like oh wow it's so you know a
food like olive oil is so calorically
dense and so nutrient poor that it seems
harmless but when you kind of look at it
through that lens you can kind of you
have this sort of awakening moment where
you're like oh now I get it well also it
has no fiber that's the most important
thing probably you know dr. Goldhamer
always says that foods like sugar oil
and salt they're not really food they're
not found in nature in any concentrated
form and they fool our brain satiety
mechanisms and cause us to overeat
exponentially the thing is is you don't
sense any fullness from olive oil so if
I were to make you a meal of like a
gluten-free pasta brown rice pasta with
steamed vegetables in an oil-free
marinara you could have a very nice big
serving of food for about 500 calories
if you eat that same meal at a
restaurant where they'll be about 500
calories from oil from the sauce from
the pasta from the vegetables you don't
experience any more fullness they've
done studies that show that the extra
calories from oil are insidious they
slip under the radar undetected by the
mechanisms of stretch nutrient and
calorie receptors and so you know I
remember when I stopped using oil in
2008 I didn't tell my husband because he
didn't need to know I make his breakfast
lunch I send his lunch to work I make
his dinner so I stopped using it not
because of caloric density because dr.
Esselstyn said it creates heart disease
diabetes and obesity and pretty my
family was dying or dead from heart
disease I figure well why would I do
this and you don't miss it because it
you can make food delicious without it
what you can use the the nuts and seeds
if you want so about seven months after
stopping oil my husband had to go to a
formal event and he's thin six feet 160
pounds and he doesn't normally were a
belt but seven months after stopping oil
we had to go to this event he went to
put his belt on and now he can't attach
it there's no more holes he goes oh oh I
must have cancer I'm losing all this
weight and he got on the scale he had
lost like eight pounds without trying
even knowing so he was being
experimented on against his will so if
somebody that doesn't want to lose
weight that doesn't need to lose weight
will lose weight that effortlessly just
by stopping oil imagine what could
happen if people actually did it on
purpose to be fair there is a little bit
of an adjustment if you're used to
eating foods with tons of oil and you
know
like lots of sugar or you know salt and
the like like you you do I don't know if
I would call it a detox but you like go
through a period where you would just
just like you would when you're
switching from milk to almond milk or
something like that like what I found
though and I'm not completely oil free
you're not but like when I'm not working
out a lot like if I'm not careful I'll
put on weight and then I have to go and
then I have to be more conscious and
very consciously aware of those kinds of
things then I and I am when I'm out
there crushing it all the time so you
know I'm very intimately familiar with
this and I've seen how it works in my
own life but I think it's you know it's
important to just acknowledge like okay
yeah it's gonna taste a little bit is it
great is it be a little bit different
but like honestly if you just go two
weeks or you know yeah I don't know a
week whatever everybody's probably a
little bit different when you complete
that cycle you know it's not really a
detox but it's an adjustment then you
land in a place where like oh I don't I
don't know the difference I can't tell I
don't I don't miss it anymore but you
have you have to go through that you're
right and most people just don't want to
do it well they don't want to do it
you're so right most people will not go
through the pain of detoxification is a
painful it's like okay I taste a little
bit different maybe it doesn't taste
quite as amazing as I'm used to but like
you know is it really that big of a deal
you're talking about a concept that dr.
Goldhamer in this book the pleasure trap
calls neurological adaptation neural
adaptation and if this in and and that
will happen the other thing people don't
understand is the role of a
neurotransmitter called dopamine in this
equation dopamine is a trans
neurotransmitter that's released when we
have a pleasurable experience such as
eating or having sex and all eating
stimulates the production of dopamine in
our brain even kale steamed kale at a
hundred calories a pound stimulate the
production of dopamine but the more
calorically concentrated the calories
the more dopamine is released well oil
is the most caloric Li concentrated food
on the planet it's 4000 calories per
pound 40 times as calorically dense as
kale and since most people aren't doing
much in life to feel good like you and
me like exercising regularly or doing
volunteer work they're relying on these
high-fat high-calorie foods to medicate
to feel good so if you take away the
most calorically dense food they're
going to feel bad because they're not
having their drug maybe that's why
when you challenge the high fat camp
they get so testy yeah I wanted to show
you I didn't bring my dryer you're
basically you're threatening to take
away that dopamine absolutely absolutely
you know I get people that come to me
and they go oh I'm Greek I'm Italian I
you know I olive oils in my blood and
saw poor Mac up and I'll go here drink
it
they won't you'll vomit if you drink it
it's because people are looking to food
to medicate to celebrate and they're not
like you say they're not dealing with
what's really going on and that's really
what it is is it's because I I would
challenge you that I could make the food
taste delicious without oil because I
was a restaurant chef that didn't use
oil I think some of my recipes are that
good but what they're missing is the
high hit of dopamine I sorry no what do
you got there well it's just funny
because I didn't bring my jars but yeah
I brought you all these snacks so it's
again I recently spoke at a veg fest and
I had to take two planes on Southwest
because there wasn't a direct flight so
on the first leg of the flight they gave
me this and on the second leg they gave
me this now rich crackers cookies in
peanut girl no it's this food that I can
fit in the palm of my boat basically in
the palm of my hands this is over a
thousand calories mm-hmm
what I eat for lunch which is usually
like two pounds of potatoes or sweet
potatoes baked into fries or roasted and
a pound of broccoli has less calories
than this like this huge plate of food
and this is if people think nothing of
eating this on their flight it's just a
little snack yeah and it's probably
thirty does I don't know a lot it's a
lot of fat this is nothing yeah it's
crazy and you can have so many fruits
and vegetables and whole grains and
legumes and rice and beans for the same
amount in processed food right I you
know people say to me all the time like
aren't you just starving all the time
are you guys massive amounts of foods
you know like gigantic you know I'll eat
like five potatoes and all you know just
unbelievable I'm full all the time I
know it's so fun and people if they
until they really understand caloric
density and actually implement it they
don't realize that as slender people we
can eat so much more food we can take in
twice as much food but yet still consume
half as many calories and again dr.
rolls is the one that discovered this at
Penn State
she wrote a series of books on it I
didn't I didn't discover color I mean I
discovered it I didn't invent it I think
I just honed it for people that
especially want to be plant-based and
what I like about your story is is that
there's this evolution like you're
you're like a chef in the in the
plant-based world in the vegan world
like you're doing cooking demonstrations
at true north yes for you're actually
fully understanding kind of what you
talk about now like so this didn't
happen overnight you are immersed in
this subculture and yet still you
weren't fully clicking with what needed
to be done to get your own health under
control I think dr. Goldhamer again him
and dr. Lyle it's almost like a
conspiracy a friendly when he tricked me
because you know when I arrived at true
north you know 50 pounds heavier he
didn't say you know you're fat don't be
you know don't be doing cooking demos
but he said something like and I can't
remember exactly but he said something
like you know you're already very
talented you're very talented chef he
goes and we judge a chef's salad by how
they can concentrate things like sugar
fat and salt and he goes you know but if
you got skinny you would rule the world
he goes you're already a [ __ ] but if
you were a skinny [ __ ] and so he did
sort of like like the white washing of
the fence with the Tom Sawyer
you know remember like where they made
it seem like a chore was fun and he made
it seem like it was gonna be so great to
be thinner for just in general and and
that he could actually help me do it
like he really gave me hope like that he
could actually explain to me how to do
it and in empowering you rather than
shaming it exactly and and and I started
those two guys are like my brothers man
I mean like if I hadn't met them I don't
know where my life would be how long
were you a true north I was only there
eight days the first time but I've since
been back every year several times a
year not as a patient but as a visiting
chef right all right so a couple
questions about this first of all for
people that are listening true true
north is the same facility that you saw
in what the health if you watch that
movie and get ready for another song
sorry yeah are you gonna sing song and
if you saw that movie you recall there's
a couple case studies in the documentary
where there's people that are on all
kinds of crazy meds and they're
overweight there was that person who
could barely walk and you see kind of
what
happens after however long their tenure
was there where they seem to be doing
much better but that's the same place
and it's also the home of Michael
clapper recently left there for seven
years and now he's he has he just
retired from True North in December but
there's other wonderful he's wonderful
absolutely they have doctor Lim now who
is the medical director of the mcdougal
program there they have dr. Peter salt
Anna they have doctors Solera so they
have other wonderful medical doctors and
naturopaths all right what one thing I'm
interested in in what goes on there has
to do with the fasting aspect I mean
we're seeing emerging science that is
speaking to the health benefits of
intermittent fasting and and what can be
achieved but there's also you know look
this can go wrong also there's people
that don't do this properly and they get
sick or you know potentially suffer some
nasty consequences so what is the what
is the relationship of the fasting
aspect to the rest of what goes on right
so it is a medically supervised
therapeutic water-only fasting center
it's been there for over 32 years
founded by dr. Alan Goldhamer and his
wife dr. Jennifer Morano however not
everybody that goes there fasts or
people like me that medically cannot
fast there are people there that don't
want to fast me because it's too scary
or too hard so they have to other levels
of care one is that you can do a juice
fast which I think could be safe for
people sometimes to do at home I would
never recommend people do a water fast
without medical supervision because they
check on you all the time they're taking
your blood pressure they're checking
your temperature they're checking your
blood and your urine so I personally
would not recommend people water fasting
at home and they fast people up to 40
days believe it or not that's wild even
slender people for certain medical
conditions water only water only many
people in the plant-based movement like
dr. Esselstyn and dr. Campbell have
actually gone there and fasted I
remember dr. Campbell had that Agent
Orange or something and TrueNorth
actually helped his recovery so so we
get we get a lot of famous people there
not just in plant-based but like in the
real celebrity world too because they
help people with certain conditions like
type-2 diabetes autoimmune disease heart
disease in almost every condition get
better and get better faster and doing
like if the complete abstinence of food
except for pure distilled water and
complete rest and so that that's their
highest level of care and that's why
most people seek them out but then again
not everybody can or will fast but even
if you do fast you can't yeah eat at
some point you have to go home eating so
if you fast you have to have at least
half that much time to repeat you can
also go there as an unrestricted feeder
which is the funnest and that's what I
go which means all you do is eat the
food three times a day
buffets set up in caloric density all
you can eat delicious food by Chef Bravo
and chef Mauricio and people still get
well people still get well just eating
this SOS free low-fat whole food
plant-based diet and they have lectures
twice a day ten o'clock in two o'clock
and when I'm there during Christmas
three times a day sometimes they'll have
a go every year
I've been going every year for eight
years and it's and I'm like that I'm
like what do you still get out of it
just no community you know I got having
the childhood that I had holidays are
very painful for me most of my family is
dead and so it's like it's a place to go
so I've been going there every year for
Christmas anywhere from ten days to five
weeks and we do the holidays there and
we have camaraderie and game I'm like
the social director so we have the best
time and it's some people do fast at the
holidays but most the people don't and
we have special demos and Iron Chef
competitions I get out of going just
it's like going home it's like it's the
home I ever had and it's it's it's a
privilege and an honor to be able to do
that so so a lot of people just do
unrestricted feed or you know so funny
because I remember even though it's been
years since I've been on your podcast
people found out about true north
because I sang that song and people were
a true north from hearing me on your
podcast so the ripple effect is
incredible they're so you you have these
levels of care and what's interesting is
a dr. Gould I don't probably get mad at
me for saying this because he's always
full but I had to attend a wedding in
the Napa Valley and dr. Goldhamer
charges less a day than any hotel so I
just stayed there for three days with my
husband and and used it as a hotel and
got all my meals it's pet friendly I
under certain circumstances yes so so
people in dr. pam popper says she does
the same thing because we're also gonna
get food like that and people you get
the
education you get the camaraderie it's
about a half a mile away from where dr.
mcdougal runs his program his program
doesn't run all year round like true
north it's it's it's an incredible
experience and if Minh wish for anyone
that was struggling with any kind of
lifestyle disease or weight issue if
they could just experience the level of
healing that goes on there it would make
all the difference in the world to them
mm-hmm but for somebody who who can't
find their way there
I mean you've worked with I don't know
2,000 people this points helping them
right learn how to lose weight and keep
it off and I kind of want to get into
you know some of the strategies that
you've employed like what works what
doesn't and you explain all of this in
the book yeah it's not it should be at
there's no no no we're not doing the
book we're just doing a cover right
so so I mean that's a that's a that's a
huge you know test group of people yeah
you've worked with right so before we
dig into the specifics cuz I want to
talk about travel and expense I'm and
all that kind of stuff but what have you
learned that might be non-obvious to
somebody listening about like what
doesn't work and what works that that
like you just wish people really I wish
people would know if they're struggling
and I think you probably know this is it
if you're an addict of any kind
moderation never works and they knew
this isn't even mean yeah exactly I
think it was at the 17th century the
18th century there was a saint named
Saint Augustine who said that complete
abstinence is easier than perfect
moderation and if people could
understand that moderation really rarely
works for anyone but it's never worked
for an addict and it that is the hardest
concept rich for people to grasp is the
concept of abstinence because people
don't like that concept it's scary it's
gonna be difficult if they only knew
that that's where the healing lies
that's where that's where everything you
ever wanted for your health your weight
in your life lies in this concept but
because there is so much confusion
around certain foods because and again I
love all the plant-based doctors but
they're not food addicts they've never
been over
so when they say yeah a little salts
okay a little sugars okay a little
flowers okay it's okay for them but if
you're the person that's overweight and
struggling and having cravings it's not
you so you have to know who you are
mm-hmm yeah I think that that you're
absolutely correct about that and I
think what happens when you put that
word abstinence in front of somebody
their whole life forecasts in front of
them and they're they're seeing
themselves at a wedding you know
somebody's getting married that they
haven't even met yet you know like
they're just future tripping on some
situation that may not even occur and
imagining well how am I ever gonna get
through that I can't do it it's
impossible they won't even try right
that's why one day at a time yeah that's
so that's what I'm getting at like the
core principle is cheesy and as trite as
it sounds of one one day at a time it's
so powerful because when you think about
it it's it's it's very Buddhist in its
nature it's like what are you doing
right now like you know okay eat the
cupcake tomorrow total freedom
permission to eat the cupcake tomorrow
but you know what when your head hits
the pillow tonight you will have
followed you know AJ's protocol or
whatever like just get through today
make the best choices that you can and
don't worry about what's gonna happen
tomorrow it's so funny I remember one of
my first clients and their struggle was
cheese actually which is also another
addictive substance it's an animal
product a processed food kaizo
morphine's opiate and the brain kind of
thing and they said well I can't do this
and I'm like well why they go well I
can't be expected to go to France and
not eat the cheese right it's just a
story nobody they said well what are you
going to France and they go well I'm not
I go one have you ever been to France
they go I have it like oh well do you
have any plans like in the next year to
go well no I I can't even afford to go
to France but the point was as addicts
you know addicts know you're gonna throw
up that berry you're gonna throw up
you're gonna think of every reason
possible to protect that that you know
to covet that behavior pattern and
that's addiction in a nutshell like
that's like okay well yeah only an
addict would say that right exactly i if
i ever have time to write another book
it'll be about some of the excuses that
I hear why people can't do this because
that's what addicts do they make excuses
and you know you can't have both excuses
and results at the same time right yeah
it's just or even you know take France
out of it all together and it's just you
have a cheese I can't I could never give
up cheese and it's like okay well let's
let's dissect that
statement a little bit like what are you
really saying like you're just you're
holding on to an idea that doesn't serve
you and you're scared you're scared of
the alternative and what that might mean
for you but you've actually never
trodden that path yet so you actually
really don't know
and you're you're you've created this
story and you've given it so much power
but you've never actually tested the
veracity of it you know and so it's
about encouraging people and I think a
big piece of that is is the empowerment
thing you know like had he said
something different to you about your
weight it might have been you know a
very different story for you right so
the psychology of this is super
important and how you communicate that's
the heart piece that's why I refer
everyone to dr. Lisle because I'm I'm
more like dr. Goldhamer like this is the
way it is just do it and you'll be fine
and I in dr. yes I'd be you know that as
an addict like it's not it's not the
information that's not what catalyzes
change you know it's so much more
complicated and nuanced than that yeah I
I think at the end of the day most
addicts don't want to give up their drug
you know of course and then it would
yeah it's like there's us friends yeah
exactly and I think often you have to
hit rock bottom you know in my case I
don't forgot to mention this this was
also a subset of the meeting dr.
Goldhamer when I broke my knee when I
was 50 almost 50 years old in February
of 2010 you know I was 165 pounds and I
was too fat for crutches or at least I
couldn't use crutches I didn't have the
upper-body strength and I was in a
wheelchair for three months and I
couldn't take care of my daily needs I
mean I couldn't go to the bathroom
myself and it's very embarrassing and
and I said to me and that was that was
almost more of my rock bottom than even
attempting suicide because to me having
somebody help you go to the bathroom
especially if that's your husband is the
most humiliating thing in the world and
I said that I am going to do something
about this I do not want to be that
person that has to have somebody wipe
their ass that was just so degrading to
me and luckily that I soon soon
thereafter met dr. Oldham Rowan and oh
the other thing is they wanted to do
surgery and I'm afraid I'm deathly
afraid of anesthesia I had almost died
when I was 19 as an allergic reaction
and so that was the other reason because
pain is a huge motivator and Here I am
working as a pastry chef you know you
know eight hours a day and
me would just swell up so there was a
lot of forces that came together to get
me where yeah two observations about
that I mean the first thing is yes pain
is a phenomenal motivator it's the only
thing that's ever gotten me to change
you know and and the tragedy in that of
course is that you don't need to be in
pain to make a change but it goes back
to that intellectualization of
everything like pain can be your best
friend because it can be the spark that
can ignite you to blaze a new path and
so when I see somebody who's in pain or
who's in suffering who's suffering your
instinct as a human being as a
compassionate person is to try to
alleviate their pain right how can I
make them feel better and more
comfortable but you know I think that
that often the more compassionate
response to that is to say is to knotch
is to is to refrain from that instinct
and allow them to have that pain moment
because that could be their divine
moment let them know that you're there
for them that you believe in them that
that you see them but don't try to ease
it for them because that is the crucible
that can forge a brand new life it's
hard to do that right I I have got you
know dr. gold hammers voice in my head
it's - it's he's very compelling like he
says things with such force and
assuredness and one of the things he
says a lot you know people will ask him
questions well you know how much how
much meat can I have doc you know like
they're they're morbidly obese on 20
medications you know how much meat can
they have how much cheese how much wine
you know he goes how fast do you want to
be and so whenever I'm faced with like a
choice that could lead me there I I
literally hear him saying that you know
how fat sick do I want to be well I
don't want to be fat or sick anymore
I've been both and I much prefer being
slender and well it's so awesome I mean
that's the other thing you know like a
lot of people say well absence isn't
sustainable
right you have you ever heard that like
what's just not sustainable you can't
you know like how can you be expecting
to go to a wedding and not drink alcohol
or go you know here and not have that
and maybe it isn't sustainable for some
people but what I want people to know is
the joy of living is sustainable and
when you reverse a lifestyle disease no
matter how difficult it was and when you
are in recovery from an addictive
substance the this self-esteem you feel
joy you feel that's sustainable yeah and
it builds you know and it gets better
and better but it's it's experiential
yeah you can't you know somebody has to
has that have that experience for them
so if no peel there's no surgery for fur
right now we live in a culture that's
all about that killed for every and you
know God bless dr. Goldhamer for saying
that we need a little truth talk here
and that's not about like Oh take this
or it's gonna be fine like no it's not
gonna be fine actually you know you're
gonna have to like get uncomfortable and
you know what good things come from
discomfort they're not just hand
delivered to you the way that you want
them to and the more people can just
acclimate to that reality I think we'd
better hope as a culture you know what I
mean all right so let's get into some of
the things you get into in the book like
you know common subjects that come up
excuses concerns the FAQ of being
plant-based like what do I do when I
travel or I have a dinner party and like
it's too expensive and I'm gonna have to
live my life in a kitchen it's way too
complicated I don't understand all this
so like can we demystify things you know
I I come end the instant pot electric
pressure cooker or any pressure cooker
instant pots my favorite because the
truth is is you always whenever I hear
you speak you talked about how you used
to have the window diet you know the
drive-through it's true that it's never
gonna be as cheap or easy as going
through a drive-through I agree yes the
thing is is it doesn't have to be as
complicated as people are making it and
the the truth is is if they if they
realize what they're eating now let's
say they're eating breakfast lunch and
dinner for a month they're eating 30
breakfasts 30 lunches and 30 dinners and
I would wager that no one listening is
eating 30 different breakfasts every day
even if they're eating a horrible diet
in 30 different lunches in 30 different
dinners people find their favorites and
their family's favorites and they repeat
them well why can't you do that with
some plant-based healthy options that
you'll like just as much you like a
hamburger try my chip Oatley bean burger
delicious all my recipes are tested on
regular people you can find a few
recipes that will become your favorites
and repeat them the other thing is is if
people would understand that the simpler
you eat the easier this is and so
whereas many people are looking more I
need a recipe I need a recipe
you need to learn to eat food and just
having rice and beans over greens and
salsa
it's delicious that's I I know you love
that meal yeah dr. Esselstyn loves that
meal it's Adaline I teach in Mexico
everybody that lives in Mexico loves
that meal it's food think about food
instead of recipes getting a pressure
cooker can take away the argument of
time and money because when you cook
things like beans and grains from
scratch they're practically free they're
forty-nine cents a pound but it also
takes less time you can cook beans on
the stove it'll take two and a half
hours pressure cooker 10 to 20 minutes
so it's true you it's like learning a
new language you have to learn a new set
of skills but these are not that
difficult to learn for most people and
the other thing is is you can always get
somebody to do it for you that's what
dr. Lisle does he has a college or a
high school student come and do all his
prep and then he just takes it out of
the fridge you know so there it's it's
harder than people make it you know what
I'm saying now of course I think the
social aspect is always going to be the
hardest especially if you're an
extrovert if you're an outgoing person
because if you're doing something
different than everybody else that could
cause you discomfort you know if you're
the only non drinker in a roomful of
drinkers you know people look at you
like well what's the matter with you why
don't you drink you know that kind of
thing and so that's I think the hardest
thing for sometimes people to navigate
is the social aspect yeah for sure and
that's the thing that leads people out
the door right exactly
I think that's the deal you know the
traveling you know you travel full time
I travel full time the traveling isn't
that hard because we're eating food and
guess what they have food in other
countries they actually have food in
airports I mean yeah so maybe I have to
get white rice instead of brown rice but
I've been on the road for seven years
now to Mexico in Canada and in the
Caribbean and I've always been able to
find food and when I can't find food a
little bit of me what happens with me is
people are like you know like I'll be
I'll fly to San Francisco or I'll fly to
Phoenix or you know some flight that's
like an hour two maybe even three hours
and what did you would you eat in the
airport would you eat in the plane I was
like dude it's only like a couple hours
like what are you gonna starve like I
had a banana guys are people freak out
they're like what am I gonna do like I'm
in this too
I'm like you're only in the tube for an
hour and a half like it you know it's
gonna be okay they're scared they'll get
hungry that's the other great thing that
you learn at you north is that hunger is
not an emergency
and when you even if you go there as an
on faster because you have roommates
unless you want to do a buyout you
always have at least one roommate in a
different room that'll but you share a
suite when you see people there that are
slender that are older than you that are
fasting for forty days you realize you
know what if I can fly it in New York to
LA without eating the peanuts I'm not
gonna die but for most people hunger is
an emergency and I think part of it is
because they're on such a toxic diet
that it almost feels like an emergency
because they need to get that next fix
of sugar fat and salt mm-hmm yeah and
those microbes and the guys handling the
brain and and further enhancing that
craving yeah I think you know beyond the
the kind of scientific benefits of
fasting I think what's important about
that is it really rearranges your
relationship with food in the sense that
you begin to understand that this three
meals a day thing like doesn't
necessarily need to apply like we're
you'll be fine you know whatever is
going on in your thinking brain or
whatever impulses are getting fired
those signals don't necessarily need to
be heated you're not gonna pass out I
mean maybe some people do low blood
sugar I don't mean to you know minimize
those sorts of things but I think in
general it's important for people to
recognize that that the way that we've
been doing it for a long time may not be
the best way I think for some people it
really is like like a detoxification
reaction rich because if you think about
that Americans eat over 92% of their
calories from animal products and
processed food they're eating a fibrous
diet with no micronutrients and they're
always going to be driven to overeat
because they're really looking for food
with nutrients and and so I think part
of it really is physiological that how
they're getting fat but they're starving
right exactly and so that's what part of
I think the discomfort is it's not
emotional its physiological because they
may have eaten 2,000 calories from a
fast-food restaurant but their body is
starving for nutrients for fiber and so
they're always going to be looking for
more food but then they keep making that
same choice right alright so I got to be
this lunch I got to go meet with these
guys there's a big deal on the line they
want to meet at a truth Chris's
Steakhouse
I have no say in this I'm trying really
hard to be good but I need to make a
good impression with these guys I need
them to like me like I'm just gonna have
to eat steak agent no steak houses are
the most vegan friendly places to eat
believe it or not I've often gotten
healthier no I really I maybe I haven't
been I couldn't really the last time I
was in a steak house well I've been to
Morton's because I which I don't know
Ruth's Chris but I'm assuming I haven't
seen the menu but in general steak
houses can be the most vegan friendly
places more so than vegans finally if
you look at the sink side so first of
all when you're invited anywhere that
you have no control over look up the
menu I mean because if it's a place that
has more than I think two or three
locations the menu will be online so
first thing look at the menu navigate
the menu if general steak houses have
lots of sides of vegetables and most of
the time the chef will either steam or
or roast the vegetables for you without
oil you do need to sometimes call up
ahead to be sure the best time to call a
restaurant is during that window where
after the lunch runs lush lunch rush
before the dinner rush and you know call
them up and say look you know I'm sorry
I don't mean to be difficult I've heard
very good things about your restaurant
I'm gonna be there on such-and-such a
date but I'm on a very special diet
doctor's orders you know blame it on dr.
Esselstyn can't have a drop of oil and
say is there anything you can do to
accommodate me and instead of saying
well you know don't say like well I'm a
whole food plant-based vegan I can't eat
sugar oil salt flour
just say what you can eat you know and
so a steak house generally can make you
a baked potato now sometimes they put
oil on it but you can ask them not to
they can steam you some vegetables often
they have salsa as a condiment so that's
one trick you can do navigate the menu
like I've had clients go to restaurants
and they go there's nothing I can't eat
but then they realize hey you know what
they had a spinach omelet so then they
say hey I noticed you have a spinach
omelet can you hold the eggs kind of
like that check right all right so
that's the logistical tack thanks but
then we have to deal with the piece
social aspect of okay so this is where
everybody's going to be different and
dr. Lisle has a beautiful lecture on his
website esteemed dynamics comm called
the perfect personality and it's going
to depend on how
agreeable or disagreeable the person is
now I don't have a problem with that
because I'm not gonna eat somebody
doesn't want me to eat now that doesn't
mean I'm gonna be rude or socially
unacceptable but what I might do for
example one of the strategies I might
use if I'm in a corner I might say when
I get there I might say oh it looks
delicious I'm so sorry I had a late
lunch and can I just get a cup of tea or
I might say something I've used this a
lot I say all guys I'm so sorry I'm
having a colonoscopy tomorrow so I can't
I mean I do that a lot or or I might say
you know what oh my god I just came from
the dentist with a root canal my mouth I
mean there's ways you can do it without
offending people for their choices right
you know you can order it and then
excuse yourself to go to the bathroom
and come back and say oh my god I'm so
sorry I just had the worst bout of
diarrhea and vomiting I've been I mean
it depends yes so you could tell a white
lie wait you don't want to lie
dr. Lisle has some interesting
strategies yeah this is well which is to
just present it in a very casual you
know way did you say I don't know you
know I'm trying this thing I'm trying to
do this thing I know it's crazy probably
not gonna work yeah you know it's it's
doing okay but like just deflate it
don't you like oh well I'm doing this
and this is the way you you know
whatever like just try to be as casual
and lanky and perhaps self-deprecating
scene in that regard and that and that
really just diffuses everything I've
never had a problem I have I have
battles in my mind about this like I it
up to be this big thing but I've always
been able I mean now it's you know it's
like look everybody knows you don't have
to tell white lies anymore everybody
knows I don't really confront it I I did
have to you know for a long time so my
personal way of doing it is just to it's
just to be super casual about it and if
you are uncomfortable with that like you
can say you can excuse yourself and say
I'll be right back and going to the
bathroom and find a waiter and go hey
this is what I want to do can you do
that though I'm like that way you're
having that comment you're not drawing I
think people do they don't want to draw
that attention right so they don't want
to be like that person who's like
difficult yeah that everyone's gonna
talk about after right the lunch or the
dinner and just you know kind of
care of it in a quiet way and then just
be you have to say anything you don't
owe anybody anything do you want to know
a strategy that worked for a couple of
my clients for whom you know a
restaurant meal off plan could have been
life or death we're not talking about
somebody that's trying to lose 10 vanity
pounds with somebody that's really in
the throes of trying to reverse diabetes
or lose a leg or go on dialysis
literally or more right so this this
brilliant lady what she did when she was
in my program in the in person program
she had to entertain clients for lunch
and she worked near La Cienega
restaurant row so they always were
places like Lowery's and whatever but
she really took her recovery from food
addiction and diabetes very seriously so
what she did is she called up the
restaurant ahead of time because you you
know where you're going usually they
don't you don't just get some mysterious
text right like you don't last night so
they knew who or that she was meeting
the client she called up the restaurant
the night before and said listen I'm on
a very special diet doctor's orders
would you mind if I brought my food into
you I'd come early you heat it up and
played it and then charge me and the guy
says lady we do that all the time and
then she got what she could eat nobody
knew nobody batted an eye she just said
oh you know hey Frank I'll have the
usual oh so she brought it ahead of time
and she put it on the plate and they
charged her for the least expensive
entree uh-huh yeah that's interesting I
haven't heard that one but that's good I
mean that's there's some machinations
and some time invested yeah gonna want
to do that but I guess look if you're
you're on your program and this is
everything you and your life is on the
line like that's it so let me ask you
this as a recovering alcoholic would you
then drink alcohol just to not make
other people feel smarter right so so
when you're newly sober I can tell you
yeah within the first two weeks of
trying to get sober
I was already imagining you know this
bachelor party that I had committed to
going to there was no way I was gonna be
able to go to Las Vegas for a weekend
with my buddies and not drink and that
terrified me so that's very real no and
I'm not trying to be dismissive and now
I could go anywhere and you know I have
to maintain my program it's not like I I
work at it right but you know I can go
to those places as need be
I don't seek them out but you know
occasions arise where I'm in situations
I'm not normally
and I'm comfortable in my own skin but
that is because I've put a huge amount
of work yeah into that right to be able
to have that gas in the tank and get
through those opportunity situations
where you know normally that would
imperil me or somebody who's who has a
very shaky foundation for their recovery
I'm not trying to be dismissive what I'm
trying to say and this is where the crux
of this disease lies because most people
don't take food addiction as seriously
as alcohol or drug addiction no one
would if people knew you were a
recovering alcoholics different if they
never met you but nobody knowing what
they know would say to you at a family
event or a bachelor party say hey rich
you got to taste this margarita I made
it just for you just a sip people
wouldn't do that to you but with food
addicts they feel like what's the harm
one meal off plan and just like murder
what right one drink one drunk you can
live your life without alcohol or
cocaine or cigarettes or you can't live
your life without food and so knowing
what I know now if I knew then I would
have just been honest with the person
and say listen this looks delicious and
I'm so sorry I don't mean to be
difficult but I am a food addict and and
there's nothing I can have her so I'm
gonna enjoy the company and have a cup
of tea that's what I would do
alright so your your kind of road to
recovery you've got this you've premise
this or you've kind of distilled this
down to this idea of the seven seas gosh
I hope I remember now well I wrote them
down well the first C is commitment
absolutely because you have to have that
commitment I mean there's been research
with Harvard Business School that the
people that made commitments did better
many many years later than those that
didn't make commitments or you know sort
of life commitment sort of like having a
goal but having a commitment writing it
down you know miss specific of me right
exactly she's gonna eat better yeah not
just say I'm gonna eat better I'm gonna
exercise I'm never gonna eat cheese
again no you know make it make it to it
and not actually having it a time
commitment see that's why we always do
like 21 days first in my program we
don't tell you that you can't have XYZ
the rest of your life we're just like
dr. Lisle says doing an experiment for
21 days we're gonna do this in on day 22
if you want that triple cheeseburger
write it on your calendar you're going
to get it but you're just gonna make a
commitment and when you make that
commitment public like we do in the
ultimate weight-loss program or if you
have a buddy it seems to be more
powerful because then you have a cow
ability yeah of course so that goes to
the community prong of the seventh yeah
that's I think number four and you know
I think community is the one where most
people fail and most people relapse
because you brought that up that's the
hardest for people because of the social
pressure and then the second a lot of
people sorry I don't interrupt but I
think this is an important point like a
lot of people like we live in Los
Angeles there's you know whatever
there's a million people here to to kind
of Pat us on the back or whatever but a
lot of people live in places where they
don't have that community in their local
town or wherever they live right that's
why in online community that's why we
created ultimate weight loss to also be
online to help people all over the world
with a virtual community which actually
can be just as powerful although it is
always nice to have somebody in person
alright compliance compliance is my
favorite word some people say they don't
like it they like adherence better but
adherence doesn't start with C but dr.
Goldhammer says the word compliance
that's right learned it and it literally
means just following a prescribed course
of action and what I love about it is
there's no emotion to me at least
there's no emotion in the word
compliance people you know all the time
make posts on our private group or call
me up and say I was bad I ate a cookie
all I was good today ate kale I don't
look at it as like you're bad or you
might be bad or good in life but you're
not bad or good based on your food
choices
you're either compliant or non-compliant
you made a choice yeah so choose to be
compliant you you you you had a mishap
you had a slip or a misstep or a relapse
then you can go back to choosing to be
compliant in the next meal whatever that
program is yeah because because it takes
this idea of failure and the shame that
kind of goes hand-in-hand with it out of
it because what happens is people slip
or make that choice and then they beat
themselves up so they've made a second
mistake and then they're like [ __ ] it
then they cope so then they're out right
and and if you reframe that and call it
by different names I made this choice
it's neutral you're not bad or good you
this is the choice that I've made okay
that allows you to be dispassionate
about it and go how can I recalibrate or
what led me to make that choice like
let's look at that let's unpack that and
what do I need to do so that I don't
make that choice again and it's how they
talk to themselves because if they ate a
cookie and then relapse and they say to
himself well now I
now I've blown it what's the use they
feel a certain way versus there's a
lifetime of energy behind that or if
they saved it thyself oh I ate a cookie
I was non-compliant it doesn't have the
same charge was like I wasn't compliant
oh well then you'll be compliant with
the next meal all right the next is
consistency as an athlete you know how
important consist all the time because I
mean you know I remember I don't I think
it might have been Doug Lyall but that
was it was it Kobe Bryant who there's
some athletes that they don't just go to
practice like they stay two hours later
or come two hours before you know things
like that when you do things in the same
manner over time without with little
variation and you do them consistently
first of all you build a habit then it
becomes an automatic habit but too many
people go to TrueNorth once a year and
fast and they lose some weight and they
get off some medications but then they
go right back to the same environment
and the same way of eating because
they're not doing it consistently so
what you do most of the time is more
important than what you do some of the
time so being consistent with your food
choices and your exercise yeah it's
self-evident
yeah that's pretty elementary but I
think that's that's the most difficult
thing I mean I think I think it's
important to respect momentum if you
have that experience of being a true
north or you've done 30 days or 21 days
of whatever you're doing we have this
weird human impulse especially addicts
of trying to celebrate those benchmarks
like I'm doing the thing that is at odds
with what got you there like like oh I
got a year of sobriety here's a yeah or
here's a cake yeah like yeah I haven't
kept very exactly you know and and and
and China maintained it's those micro
little decisions that you're making
every day that are truly at the crux of
whether you're gonna succeed or not and
that's the unsexy part you know it's
like oh you can create all this
romanticization out of like getting on a
plane and going to true north and like
you're housed and you're taking care of
but like you know what are you doing at
home when no one's looking moment to
moment Howard an hour it's funny that
you mentioned the word sexy I had this
very affluent client that came to me and
I playing the program and he goes you
know this abstinence it's just not sexy
and I said well there is your impotence
so yeah because he'll also like nothing
you know nothing truly no great
accomplishment is really like what it
takes to
build a company or you know achieve any
athletic Heights or any of these things
like it's it's the unsexy part that gets
you there it's the thing that you're
doing your grind when no one's looking
at you're doing anonymously like all of
that is what contributes to that success
building so much self-esteem with doing
that that's the thing that's so cool
yeah of course
and when you look back it's those
difficult moments that you recall you
know it's not like that you know you
could celebrate these victories but
honestly like the value for me when I
look at anything and I've created or
succeeded out like I remember like the
heart effort its you know dr. Lisle
talks about that it's that you rewarded
for the effort for a job well done
you know I do a lot of these Iron Chefs
and I don't always win but I don't feel
bad when I lose I if I if I know I did
my best you know that's all that matters
of course the next one's changed is
changed no it's cooking okay sorry I
don't remember the order cooking you
know it used to be continuing education
and then I changed it to cooking because
we realized that at some point you have
to get the food right and either that
means learning a few simple basic
recipes yourself as we talked about or
having somebody cook it for you because
the food seems to be a part that eludes
a lot of people you know I had a client
44 years old who came to me she goes how
do you bake a potato and I'm like oh my
god you know people have no skills
anymore like when I grew up home
economics was mandatory in junior high
sewing and cooking we learned basic you
know skills of the of the homemaker
which I think men and women should
should learn so it's just some basic
cooking skills right all right cooking
change change yeah you know you know
that's saying nobody likes change but
what baby but many people don't change
until the pain associated with change is
less than the pain of staying the same
people have to at least be willing to
change because you're going on a journey
here that's completely different than
anything you've ever done right because
most of the world is gonna continue to
eat crap and continue to eat animal
products and so at least you have to be
willing to make these changes you may
have to change who you hang out with
like if you were when you were an
alcoholic if you had other buddies that
were alcoholics you probably couldn't at
least I try to completely change myself
right or at least not hang out with them
at the bar anymore so you have to be
willing to change who you
with if you still go to restaurants you
might have to change which restaurants
you go to how you or how you order so
that's a big thing for people a lot of
people don't like having to change
no no they really don't know you know
they want they want it they want all the
good stuff right but they don't want to
do those uncomfortable things exactly
so AJ's got news for you yeah you gotta
learn to get comfortable being
uncomfortable right well we talked about
community do you have anything more to
say about that I think with community is
that if you don't have one find one in
whether it's my group or a virtual group
or even just one person that this could
be a buddy to you online or in person I
think that that is really going to be
the most important thing it would be
very you know if my husband didn't
support me in this I don't think I could
do it you know if he was just you know
drinking beer and eating pizza every
night so even having that one special
person to support yeah so what do you
say to that person who is really trying
hard but their spouse their partner is
not a nice a good get divorced no so
what I sometimes I do say that if
they're not if they're sabotaging them
so what I say is then you know at least
don't have these things in the house so
in other words if you're an alcoholic
and your spouse isn't and they can still
drink out of respect to you they will
then drink outside of the home and it
has to be the same thing with the foods
or we recommend even getting what's
called a locked food safe if your spouse
won't support you it's going to be rough
now all the doctors I've interviewed
says say that a loving partner will
support someone in recovery or at least
should that doesn't always happen so if
your spouse won't support you then you
have to get it somewhere else it's very
hard to do this alone no man is an
island and recovery I know one person
that was a cocaine addict that was
extremely introverted highly intelligent
that was able to get off the drug
themselves without rehab without you
know going to a doctor that's really
rare recovery is generally done in
programs because it really helps you to
see that if you climb this mountain
there is a top you when you see people
like Heather Goodwin who have lost 300
pounds it kept it off you see what's
possible and that's why I think if you
don't have the support at home you've
got to find you as we say your tribe
somewhere yes a support system is
absolutely crucial not just to see the
example the successes but also just to
catch you when you fall and yeah you
know who you gonna call at midnight and
you know all that kind of stuff is like
I couldn't I couldn't gotten sober
myself there's no way I know you know
there's no way so I think it's
SuperDuper important all right
compassion
oh that's might be a problem that's why
wore this shirt today that's not
compassionate I'm not dis compassionate
but most of my life as an ethical vegan
my compassion was more for those with
fur and fins and feathers and not those
so much with skin don't like people well
it's not I don't like them but I always
seem to do better with you know the
animals and so I I realized that you
know if I'm going to be successful
helping people and if people are gonna
be successful helping themselves you
have to have compassion for other people
at every step of their journey and for
yourself especially when you relapses at
people people if they understood what an
insidious chronic progressive
life-threatening disease addiction was
whether it's food addiction or alcohol
addiction they might be kinder to
themselves when they relapse you know
it's it's so you need to practice self
compassion and there's a you know like
your wife teaches yoga and meditation
those are two of the most beautiful
modalities that help you
garner self compassion when you can get
quiet and do those more mindful things a
lot of people have compassion for the
animals but not so much for other people
and that's that's what I'm talking about
with compassion however there are people
that come to this program just to lose
weight and really don't have compassion
for the animals and then it's a
plant-based program and then they maybe
need to learn to have some compassion
for those so it compassion is huge you
know
yeah the piece about self compassion is
super important you know somebody's been
in in you know the rooms of recovery for
a long time like you see people that
relapse there's chronic relapse or a lot
of those people are under the
misapprehension that they can go out and
they can always come back which they can
but you know just because you go out
doesn't mean you're going to come back
and and you know more often than not you
know I've been witness to those people
that go out thinking they're gonna come
back after a binge weekend and they
never come back never come back that's
because of shame and because you know
sometimes they die and let they know a
lot of funerals but you know a lot of
times is just they're so mortified
can't face the prospect of returning to
the rooms to admit on a public level
like he says what happy and so they
would rather imprison themselves and
perpetuate the addictive cycle then have
to actually confront that and you know
it's that destroys life absolutely and
that's why that's why community is so
important addiction is a disease that
can only thrive in isolation and that's
just the way it is and they they they
shouldn't feel so much shame I think
that's why with with shows like yours to
educate people that addiction actually
it's a disease like you interviewed dr.
Mattei it's not it's not like a choice
it's not like we said oh you know this
this great thing to have it's it's it's
our brains are wired differently than
other people's and even though it is
it's not a choice but once we know that
we are wired this way it becomes our
responsibility to behave differently if
we wish to recover which is why if I had
one message for people that were
suffering from any addictions it would
be that abstinence is bliss it is so
much easy to stay easier to stay in
recovery than it is to continually have
to detoxify and withdraw and try to get
sobriety again whatever your addiction
is but but like I said I've never met
anybody that's gone to the top of the
mountain or got to the other side that
didn't think abstinence was it's so
awesome if they could just feel what it
was like to be in our brains to have a
calm brain and not having cravings for
any addictive substance people would do
it but it is a tough sell yeah it is so
we got to round this out but if
somebody's listening to this and they
are caught in that cycle and they're
having difficulty you know confronting
their own personal truth or trying to
see their way out of it
what is your lifeline might well I think
that the first thing I would probably
recommend is maybe read a book like the
pleasure trap you know there that's a
low buy-in like you know what is it like
15 bucks or 20 bucks on audible and see
if that resonates with you what these
doctors are saying and if it does maybe
considering going to true north or at
least having your free consult you know
there's no there's no cost and just
talking to dr. Goldhamer to see if it
was right for you or having a low-cost
consult with dr. Lyle for $75 if my
program is right for you consider
joining that you don't mean it's not
right for everybody because it is it's a
it's an abstinence based program and
that's the thing
people want the results of abstinence
without doing the work of abstinence so
and and just just get yourself educated
more to see if you really are an addict
you know there is no shame in this
disease unless you feel that way you
know that's why we need to bring this
out and I mean I'm proud to say I'm an
addict because once I found out I was I
knew I could recover because there was
treatment before that that's when I
thought something was wrong with me that
I couldn't I couldn't eat a cookie I'm
like what's wrong with me who eats you
know all these cookies I don't get it
but once I knew that there was a reason
there was no more shame right so often
the fear of the unknown exceeds the pain
of the the current situation right and
and and I also I think it's it's often
revealing if you get out a piece of
paper and draw a line down the middle
and write on one side like all the pain
that you're suffering from and on the
other side what you're afraid of and and
really get real with yourself you know
willingness is something that you can't
you can't will somebody to be willing
they have to have their own sort of
desire to you know do that kind of work
and they either have it or they don't
and my hope and my wish for everybody
who's listening who is suffering is that
you do have that willingness because is
that that will make the difference
between you you know changing your life
and just maintaining stuck in whatever
path you can always go back you can try
sobriety if you don't like it you know
it you know it's not none none of these
programs or court-ordered well sometimes
I guess they are for some people but in
general in general you know that's why I
love the concept of not even a day at a
time but a meal at a time a bite at a
time you can always choose to go back
and I don't know if I heard this on one
of the guests in your show but you know
they say that the opposite of addiction
is connection and that's why absolutely
that's why it's so important to find a
tribe or at least one person to support
you awesome AJ you're an inspiration oh
thank you I love you how do you feel I
feel great
my hairdresser says she's your biggest
fan and she was so jealous that I was
coming here I have a massive fan base
amongst hairdresser do she's a vegan
hairdresser oh cool yeah that's cool
really great if you want to connect with
AJ there's a number of
to do that the most important thing
though is check out her new book secrets
to ultimate weight loss she also has a
book called eat unprocessed unprocessed
yeah process yeah check that out and
your website your coaching your online
programs on my website chef AJ website
yeah or eat unprocessed calm yeah cool
nice you're on all the social networks
are you speaking anywhere what's coming
up the cruise is until next year you
know I've been taking a little time off
to to to to get this book done am I
going anywhere special no oh Rancho La
Puerta where you've been with Julie yeah
in Mexico may may 5th through 12 yeah I
had Deborah on the podcast early days as
well cool she's amazing she's awesome
how old is she must be like like 95 or
96 now yeah she stole she stole showing
up and doing her she's she's the goddess
I love her no she's cool alright awesome
come back and talk to me again sometime
oh my god it'd be my honor pleasure
thank you peace plants eat unprocessed
Oh